don't worry buddy another YouTube hang
out super pumped to be here I've got a
new friend with me Chris runs a podcast
called the entrepreneur hour and he
wanted to interview me for his podcast I
said yes let's do it but how about
wheels make it a YouTube video so I can
expose him and his ideas to you guys so
before get him into the questions and
Chris will run into you know his intro
for his show Chris welcome aboard man
how you doing hey man thanks for having
me good to be here quickly for my
audience just give a little background
what you do what the entrepreneur's
about and where they can find you
totally so started my first business
from my college apartment that's my
brother and I and had really no
intention to do anything other than just
to pay our bills were in college you
know I kind of always was
entrepreneurial starting businesses when
I was in high school even back to middle
school just lawncare you know in this
stuff that's outside of the hour for pay
model lo and behold we got traction
unexpectedly got traction with that
business in college we found ourselves
scaling the 1.2 million dollars within
36 months with that business doing doing
operations in 32 states or in the
country working with five of the seven
nature furniture turnkey providers so I
was having all these like incredible
conversations with people you know other
entrepreneurs and mentors things that
nature and I just said and these
conversations are so powerful they're so
impactful to me why aren't we recording
this in like you know paying it forward
and giving back to the entrepreneurial
community a lot of things that you know
I always said this but if I had known x
6 months earlier than what I actually
learned it may be what my journey would
have been a little bit easier because
truth be told a lot of people think
scaling is a lot of fun and it while it
is it certainly it's very very difficult
to scale at that kind of a rapid rate in
a matter of 36 months so that's kind of
how the show came to fruition as you can
tell get on my on a podcast and giro set
up in here so I look like a true
podcaster right so lo and behold man
within two weeks of launching the
podcast we were top five new and
noteworthy under business health and
education and we probably been two major
guess truant from like 30 downloads a
day we first launched in the first
couple of days to like thousands a day
and it just has been just a crazy ride
but i think it's it's been exciting it's
been exciting to hear from the on from
your community and though they're
getting value out of the show and then
you know last week interview dane
John from shark tank and so it's an
awesome for me to connect with those
just incredible mooers people like
yourself that otherwise I wouldn't have
really an opportunity to connect with or
maybe you just wouldn't have come to
fruition or what it taken me months and
months and months to like fine you know
the medium to connect so that's kind of
my story in a nutshell i'm also now
involved with several endeavors out here
on base in the atlanta area i love it
man well thank to the intro and turn it
over to you whatever you need to do for
your podcast here we go let's do it
let's do it so I want to flip the
question on you then so come about your
journey into a major life event things
that kind of led to what you're doing
now so I can give you a high level and
then if you want to dig deeper on any of
those things let me know happy to go
further growing up I never thought I was
going to be an entrepreneur I had a lot
of entrepreneurial tendencies selling
art selling baseball cards a bunch of
different things but I didn't have any
entrepreneur immediate kind of community
so I thought I want to be a banker it's
look at my high school yearbook we're
going to be in 10 years vp8 of banks
where I thought my tracks was going to
be I go to university and I'm on that
path to be a banker connect with two
entrepreneurs who need help and I joined
their business as one of the owners and
we struggle a lot make it three hundred
dollars a month and you know barely able
to survive I get opportunities to get
those dream jobs at banks we're learning
80-100 k a year and it decides not to do
those and do this business that is not
making money the hardened skin of my
life and then from there end up sucking
some more my company finally find a
turnaround point and a couple years
later we get acquired and we can go to
that if you want from there became a
venture capitalist to raise half a
million 15 million for companies want to
expand and now started helping
entrepreneurs and had a popular website
have a couple of YouTube channel have a
book with painting random house and my
goal is to help a billion entrepreneurs
and that's what fuels me daily yeah and
I really want to get it because I think
that's awesome that you have that
mission and I want to talk to you he's
like everything you've done as far as
your branding is concerned if is like
your power statement of belief so kind
of talk about
what that power statement means to you
and then how important is for
entrepreneurs to have that positive
mindset so I believed everybody has one
word inside them they have one core
value that makes up who they are it's
the topic of my book that came out for
me it's believed and it's more than just
a marketing thing I think a lot of
people see that that's great brand and
that's great mar download yeah and it is
it is it's great market but it's
authentic to me its Who I am its what i
do believe for me comes from my parents
it's the reason why I have a picture of
me at seven years old up on my wall with
my parents behind me they would always
teach me those at Casterly Carmichael I
could do anything that I wanted well so
whenever I didn't do well at school or
you know whatever it was got it the
problems the answer would always be your
cuz truly Carmichael you will get
through this you could do anything that
you want and so believe a lot came from
them and I think it's important to
understand what you do stay in for and
then start to live that life for the
entrepreneurs out there bring that to
your business as well and so
understanding i was about believe and
that was my most important core value I
didn't really know that until later on
in life but that now allowed me to get a
turbocharged into my business grow a lot
faster make better content connect with
people on a higher level and also have a
lot more fun make a lot more money feel
like I'm doing you know purpose driven
to work and that allows you to go out
and have a big impact yeah so when did
you find the platform of you know
creating content doing video and things
of that nature just kind of stumble upon
doing that it started actually on my
website so the thing that contains my
company early on was modeling success
when I realized I'm not the first kind
of trying to do this before somebody
already done it let me figure out who
and model the success that saved me from
going from three hundred dollars a month
to actually having a paycheck and
building arraylist and so I modeled Bill
Gates how we started 021 I wanted to
learn that and so I then built the
website to try to help entrepreneurs
avoid some of the struggles that I faced
early on in my career and I shared the
stories of all these same with
entrepreneurs hoping that people could
learn from them I was learning myself
yet another could learn from them to
hopefully avoid it
baldan month from their success and that
evolved into a YouTube channel just
because I'm much more of a visual
learner I would rather see something
then we hit and so if I could if I could
read Steve Jobs his speech that's great
but if I could see him delivering it it
just touched me more deeply I resonated
with it more I was able to understand it
more and so it evolved to a YouTube
channel because it's much more of a
visual medium so it started selfishly
for me to learn more about these famous
entrepreneurs to continue to my to build
my growth and I shared it with others
and thankfully people have been inspired
as well buy it and continue to come back
well I think it's really interesting
because you talked about how believe is
unique and authentic to you and how the
video so you created things that really
were all CENTAC and you need to you and
that really is what's made your brand
take off it sounds like so that's really
like fascinate just make it just be your
best unique self you know yeah and when
I first found the leave I thought it was
too bold too big an idea other people
have done it before right right now
Justin Bieber had his believe tour and
share how to sound or got about that
yeah yeah it was a whale as I'm show at
SeaWorld called believe you know it's
like it's been used but I think what
happens a lot especially bunch of words
is we talk ourselves down some big ideas
yeah I'm up with a big idea to this is
great here's how we can go and you know
change the world rah rah and then the
next day it's not even our friends and
our family who put us down with
ourselves we are our own worst enemy the
next thing you ain't comin to that idea
that we had that's too big like I can't
do that at all I want the resources or
the capability to do that and we talked
ourselves down from doing the big bold
things and so I didn't want to not do it
because that was afraid of doing
something bold I think that happens way
too often for entrepreneurs then you
talked about your parents were they were
they both entrepreneurial entren or
driven or kind of had they feel about it
when you start pursuing
entrepreneurships they are not
entrepreneurial at all you know I dad
work for the government is basically his
whole life and then retired and became a
consultant the thing that was great
about my parents were they always
encouraged us to do whatever
wanted and they may not feel like we
could do whatever we wanted and so these
live more traditional lives and I think
in part because you know and my mom's
side her parents kind of grew up a lot
more strict and she didn't have the
freedom to do some of the things she
wanted to do until the result was I'm
going to give my kids lots of freedom
and confidence and belief and so I have
two sisters i'm in the middle all three
of us went totally different wacky
creative path my older sister did a
bunch of Silicon Valley startups and you
know it's raising money and CEO of a new
company down there my younger sister
went to Africa for ten years and worked
for the UN oh wow helping child soldiers
come out of the you know the war zone
and helping them you'll get back to
normal life and just awesome crazy stuff
and so none of us have led a traditional
none of us led to traditional life that
my parents LED and I carried a dsm
instilling that belief enough that we
can do whatever we wanted yeah go man
well so you talked a little bit earlier
you talked about helping and inspiring a
1 billion entrepreneurs which is quite
an ambitious feet you're setting out for
yourself but but talk about what the
world would look like they're kind of in
big ambiguous or vague question but talk
about what that would actually mean
socio-economically to to the world in
general what kind of impact would that
make or as you see it how you envision
it would I think all the world's
problems will be solved by entrepreneurs
I think it's on us to save it I don't
think it's going to be the government or
who the president is or big corporations
you know the innovation happens from
entrepreneurs yeah and countries like
wars are stopped because of economics
because it's a lot of trade that happens
because of us doing the work and so I
think major problem which is if you're
looking at you know health care and
diseases or if you're looking at space
exploration or if you're looking at you
know world peace or whatever it is I
think it's going to be solved by
entrepreneurs and I think a lot of
people have a genius-level talent at
something inside them that they're not
ever going to go and do because they
never tried it now they're stuck doing
menial job that they don't like they
hate going to work every day where they
have some something inside they could
really contribute to the world and not
doing it you know I don't know what's
your favorite sport so watch football
play basketball okay so football who's
the greatest quarterback of all time but
it's got to be right now I mean you can
and argue with that now it's just it's
timely right it's timely okay so like
what do you something I would have said
Montana but it's got to be Brady now
well you know whether you see Brady
whether you see Montana weather like you
know Troy Aikman there you know whatever
your hometown hero I would say it's none
of those guys I would say the greatest
quarterback of all time is a manager at
McDonald's because he never actually
picked up a football and he didn't know
that he had that genius level talent and
so you got like Brady Brady is maybe
like number 100 on the list there's a
ton of guys who would have more
potential but they never picked up a
football and that's what that's what
upsets me like people have a lot of this
untapped genius inside of them and
instead of going off and doing the thing
that they could have tom brady like
genius level talent at they're stuck in
a crappy job that they hate that you
know pays the bills and they look
forward to the weekends in the evenings
and so if everybody does a billion
people off doing their thing and
showcasing like imagine a billion people
being Tom Brady at what they're doing
that's an amazing world that I want to
be a part of right no I always I always
think about that as far as like what
stops us from actually pursuing those
things and if you think about in the
grand scheme of life looking back at
it's like my nightmare is that I didn't
pursue that not that I didn't accomplish
this that or whatever but like that I
didn't actually pursue my drinks to the
fullest that's the only way you lose is
the only you fail in my mind you know
yeah i think what stops people is
self-awareness and fear yep yeah right
like I didn't know that I could be an
entrepreneur like I had all these
tendencies growing up but unless I met
those two people in university I
wouldn't have been an entrepreneur would
have gone down the banking path until
the self-awareness is important and then
the fear to actually go and do something
and not just take that idea you have and
sit on it but to take action and one of
the ways to combat the fear of taking
action is the
greater fear of regret it's the Jeff
Bezos regret minimization framework that
he tells it where I can click right
you're like I'm just no looking back on
your life or you're going to regret
doing this and if you are then that make
an important decision and that can give
you the courage to break through
whatever short-term fear you have right
right well you act on it and that's
great so let's talk then about so far in
your career as an entrepreneur what has
been like you're most proud or rewarding
moment um that's a hard one you know I
don't celebrate it almost at all um you
may have in common yeah I honestly I
think I think high performers don't
celebrate that much yeah you know like
you look at Tom Brady you say greatest
quarterback of all time great 15 Super
Bowls okay like I'm sure he's
celebrating you know day of the parade
but what these already on of the next
yeah it's like 2018 Super Bowl let's go
guys we're like five weeks behind let's
start training right so I have a tough
time with that question because i don't
i don't know like I'm proud of a lot of
stuff and but I don't really look back
that much it's like okay let's keep
going let's have a big impact let's keep
getting better let me shift the question
then what has been the most powerful
message that you've gotten from someone
in your audience or a follow or somebody
that you work with it that they've
really demonstrated man you've done this
for my life felt a bit easier yeah I
mean here's one because I get I mean
unfortunately sure you're at this spot
now to where you get a lot like daily
assists it's amazing i get a couple
hundred comment today and a lot of them
are insane life changing stuff I
remember one's own particular it was on
a video we did I think it was magic
johnson the basketball player not an
entrepreneur now as well and there was a
guy who watched the video and he left
the comment and he said my parents
taught me growing up that black people
are really stupid hmm and this video
just totally changed my perspective
Wow like that's nuts right like that
filter that I'm involved with is it's
changing people's perspective on things
like racism and opening our minds to
different points of views what you're
not just insulated by your immediate
environment of your parents and family
and community because you grow up in a
crappy environment changes are you're
going to you're going to be exactly like
them and listening to the entrepreneur
hour or watching videos or reading
biographies and you know surrounding
yourself with better knowledge can help
you break free broaden your perspective
and give you the chance to go out and do
something amazing and so that one in
particular stands out is that's I mean
that sucks that he grew up in that but
like how amazing is that like something
I made totally change his perspective
yet I wonder how old he was how long
he's been he's been operating without
limiting belief yeah and and then would
continue it on to his kids no idea for
generations absolutely yeah that's great
that's crazy that's awesome though
alright so let's shift gears let's talk
about you know where do you take your
efforts from here you know region 2
billion people like I said that's a
pretty lofty goal albeit it looks like
you're well on your way but what does
that look like what does the future look
like for Evan Carmichael and what you're
going to be doing is in books is it
continuing to build your your video
presence mean what is that going to look
like for your entail yeah so the billing
the billing question gets asked a lot I
think there is it's not so much about
how do i track how do I hit a billion
it's more that the work that I do have
to have the potential to make a big
impact right and so I don't do
one-on-one coaching I don't have a hey
hire me for an hour and you know it cost
X amount of dollars the work that I do
has to be a scale for me to achieve what
I want to cheat so the youtube channel
lets me have a wide audience doing the
entrepreneur our let's say reach some
more people writing a book like I don't
want to self publish a book I can make
more money self-publishing a book I want
to I want with the random house because
that lets me reach a wider audience so
and so I think when you see really
successful people they are really
stubborn about the mission division the
why like this is what we're here to do
I'm here to help
billion entrepreneur this is what I'm
super passionate about wake up every day
chasing the how in the execution changes
I'm not attached to the how it's like
stubbornness to the cause but extreme
humility like I'll do anything to move
that thing forward if you told me that
like cleaning out toilets would help me
reach a billion entrepreneurs I would do
it right like I'm not above that I'll do
it I want this you know and so many
people and I'm not going to do that
that's beneath me right and the most
successful leaders nothing has beneath
them to help them accomplish that big
goal and so I can tell you where I'm
going in next couple months where we're
going to be in five years I didn't know
was going to write a book a year ago you
know five years ago I would never say
that YouTube would be where I'm spending
most of my time so in the next couple of
months I am promoting the book i'm
getting a youtube channel going it's
where I'm spending most of my time and
when I'm in the short-term midterm super
committed to in a year in two years and
five years I don't know but it's going
to be impacting entrepreneurs in a big
way whatever that looks like total
scalability yeah all right so you talked
about a guy that you need a manager
mcdonalds and he could potentially have
been v tom brokour even better than tom
brady make tom brady look like an
afterthought you know yeah talk to that
guy right now or that gal right now and
they're on the fence about whether it's
entrepreneurship were pursuing whatever
it is from pursue what would you say to
that person to get them to finally take
that leap of faith or hop over that
fence I think its first helping them
understand what it is that they want to
do like does the guy even know that you
can place the ball as they had any
exposure to it you know do you want to
go and start a business what is it in
your head like you are you happy with
your life are you happy with where
you're at right now you ask most people
that they're going to say no if they're
honest with themselves like it was a
total strangers like yeah I'm happy but
like deep down most people are not happy
with their life yeah so just getting
into that uncomfortable position where
you are analyzing because instead of
actually trying to fix something we
asleep exactly right it's so let me go I
don't want to think about my job so
let's go watch
you know Big Brother 18 yep and so just
even having the awareness to have a
conversation around listen your life is
broken you're not happy you could be
doing more you know you could be doing
more let's start figuring that out what
is that big green that maybe you could
start building towards and then giving
them the support and believe an
environment to do it what often ends up
happening is I would be a blip right
listening to one episode of the
entrepreneur would be a blip and maybe
that's enough of a blip to spark a fire
and because they're so pent up and so
ready to make a change is that one
episode at half an hour you know makes
them want to make a change but for most
people it's just a blip and then they
fall back to their regular habits and
patterns on their environment because
they have a morning routine that sucks
and environment that sucks and habitat
sucks and so you need to have a
wholesale change of your environment you
to listen to the untrained our everyday
repeat multiple episodes go back and
listen to it again right you need to
read the bio you need to start to change
your standards and that comes from
changing your environment and so the
most important thing that I try to get
out when I'm talking to some but is one
just the awareness that they don't like
their life and they're just escaping
like if you can't wait to go on vacation
and you just escaped in your life like
this vacation can be great if you're
seeking something but not just running
away from a life that you hate putting
the awareness on that and then
restructuring their environment to give
them new habits that will support them
and thinking bigger yeah I cannot could
not agree more with what you're saying
and it's interesting because you talk
about how many people are unhappy i
think i read recently i said this on
several episodes that statistic sound
that eighty-five percent of people are
currently unhappy with their career
their career path eighty-five percent
that's ridiculous to me and so it really
inspires me to do what I do in reach a
larger audience i'm sure you're the same
and i think in this day and age i'm
curious to hear your thoughts on this
but you talked about escaping it's never
been easier for us to escape you can
grab your your phone and watch just you
watch youtube videos i'm miserable so
i'm just going to play on Facebook or
social media or whatever the case would
be rather than actually deal and
confront your issues
say why am I happy and how can I pursue
that so I'm not unhappy it's we describe
distractibility we find things to kind
of take our minds away from those verses
challenging that yeah a hundred percent
I also think it's never been easier to
go and do the thing you want no
absolutely right like it's both sides
right so easy to get distracted about
Barden like yeah you're playing your
next game or whatever it is and you just
locked in your phone but at the same
time like hey the entrepreneur didn't
exist 10 years ago exactly right
podcasting wasn't around here's his
chance to listen to some great people to
listen to chris's insights and all of
his guests and you wouldn't have access
to these people hmm and so it's never
been easier at the same time it's just
replaced in a habit like taking take one
thing that you think is a bad habit
that's just keeping you where you are
and swap it like what do you do first
thing in the morning what websites you
pull up is it just like some prank video
youtube channel great how about you just
replace that with the entrepreneur every
day mmm so just make that one small
change and now you're you're actively
feeding your brain to try to get better
and build a better environment career in
life for yourself as opposed to just
escape in and just laughing at stuff
joke I'm going to pretty sure all the
plugs man thank you so anyway so talk to
me you might like my dogs are chime in
and you can hear so I always will try to
end on this pressure with resources that
you recommend books that you've read it
and I know you you're an avid reader
from what I can tell and you've got all
of these inspirational people in your
back so I can tell you have those
influencers so talk about the books that
you recommend people must must read
podcasters and to influencers they
follow and those that have impacted you
and then part two of that is where can
people learn more about you where can
they find you the youtube channel the
online presence work and they learn more
about you sure in terms of resources
that i recommend I'm again much more of
a visual learner than I am anything else
and so my recommendation honestly is my
youtube channel like I use it for myself
it sounds like a shameless plug but like
the videos I make of learning from the
same with entrepreneurs is for me to
learn and get outer my god Oh after that
i would say i love gary vaynerchuk
content on YouTube
lewis houses content on YouTube those
two guys I consume most of what they
make terms of books I'm a weird duck
like I'll consume whatever i'm
interested right now i'm interested in
adult human behavior change and so
reading about triggers triggers of the
book i just finished power of habit is
one that have coming up is a good mom
power habit yeah it's a good one all
right okay i'm going to have to look
great a little bit i'm moving closer to
the next the next read less now if I
believe what I'm gonna take as Charles
Duhigg and it's yeah it's powerful man
cool good yeah so I'm interested in that
I think in terms of my all-time favorite
books the two at the top for me or one
is the 4-hour workweek you know how much
printer classic more for just time
management helped me out a lot not so
much they're only work four hours a week
because yeah you got to work on whatever
your passion about angry and in the
other book that I really like is out of
print it's called radicals and
visionaries and it was I used to read
this when I was starting my first
business every day it's a different
famous entrepreneur and kind of three to
four pages on them so you get the head
of motivation as well as with strategies
and it's kind of what my youtube channel
has been based off of like to come every
day and this new content where you're
learning from a famous entrepreneur so
it's out of print but if you can find a
copy on eBay or something that might be
worth a read pot tax on to an hour go
check that one out i heard it's a good
like you yeah i'm not a huge podcast
consumer yeah I don't have a commute and
when I do I read as opposed to listen to
something so i'm not a huge I think for
me that the hearing is the hardest
because I'm visual so I'd like to a
video and if I care if I can't see video
I need to read it mmm you know like when
my teammates are reading me a message
that they want me to give them feedback
on I need to read it like them telling
me it doesn't compute properly for me so
I think this by why I just haven't
consumed podcast but there's there's a
lot of great ones but
the entrepreneur hours you know guys you
gotta know subscribe to that one I then
read me you know wherever wherever you
hang out I'm mostly on youtube in in
Twitter but you know I'm on snapchat
Instagram my website the book is
wherever you buy books it's called your
one word and yeah just type in heaven
Carmichael where we like to hang out
you'll probably find me yeah man you
have some cool stuff online i really
enjoyed it i was checking it out when i
doing some research about you and
actually i think i'm not mistaken that's
how we stumbled upon you i believe with
youtube i'm not mistaken we saw one of
your like the top 10 tips for success by
so-and-so or whoever you're doing like a
series on those i think that's how we
settled upon so i was like man is
powerful or you know message really
closely aligns with my messaging stuff
like that I was like all right we got it
we got chat but uh but cool man well I
appreciate taking time to be on the show
actually have never done at the same
time a live video stream while I'm
recording a podcast of this so I was a
new BTW this is fun I like it listen I
think you can have a lot of success
turning this into a youtube channel as
well for what you do come in I may just
have to do that I may just have to do
that so anyways way I appreciate Evan
take care not you know hopefully we'll
catch up soon my friend thanks to the
love man it's been awesome all right
brother seemed in all right that was
good go buddy excellent we're not live
anymore no no we're still live on my
channel but your thing is off so I got
it and then quickly for people who are
watching they want to find out about
entrepreneur our where what's the best
place to find it yeah you can go to
Chris Michael Harris com Forge / show
that will take you directly to the
iTunes it is on itunes stitcher pod bmu
name like it's everywhere my website is
Chris Michael Harris com we got a bunch
of cool like free resources whether
whatever phase your business you're in
if you're just starting out we've got
you know the ultimate server checklist
and then if you're waiting Cavill which
is kind of the clients that I work with
most of them are in cap race mode so
I've got some tips for you know I've got
a Rolodex of like over almost over a
thousand investors around the country so
a lot of like helping them connect with
investors how to prepare for fundraising
make sure they've got their books in
order to make sure they've got the
infrastructure to scale because scaling
is great but you've got to have those
foundational pieces in place so a lot of
cool resources there they can check out
then
they follow the show because we've got
some awesome guests like yourself that
come on in the weekly basis like I said
me just had Dana John I've had you know
some really new york times best thing
off there's Michael E Gerber mean you
name it so we've had some really awesome
guess it's been in been a really
powerful tool honestly you said
something that really resonate with me
when you said a lot of times like you're
doing the videos that you do and like
you're learning just as much some time
and I feel like my my level of knowledge
in terms of entrepreneurship it's like
multiplied exponentially since i started
to the podcast because like i have to
dig deep in like you know it's one thing
to learn something something else to
teach it you just like learn it in a new
way to be able to teach it to somebody
else so yeah you know it's been it's
been a really powerful tool for me to
learn as well and grow as an
entrepreneur and you know just connects
people interact with and stuff like that
so man it's been awesome I really
enjoyed it it's uh it's obvious to Chris
I mean because the questions you ask
like you're genuinely curious about them
it's not sure oh well but you know what
a lot of podcasts to litigate here arte
público and money oh so it's like it's
obvious that you're learning that you're
low and you pick your guests with you
know with the reason and I'm excited man
I might have to start getting to listen
to the podcast just to get out Rijn hour
but it is that man or I'm gonna have
certain video for you guys I go yes okay
you know why that's a deal if you start
youtube channel i will subscribe all
right on a min because i have no idea to
start a YouTube channel happy to help
dude this is it and then when is this
episode's going up okay so right now
we've got it we got it I think you're
like fifth or six in the queue so we're
looking at probably the last week of
February's so about three weeks we're
going to go live with this one cool
alright so we'll pay guys obviously
beyond social things then it should just
be on the lookout for it yessum to me
we'll share it up to anyway awesome guys
thank you for watching Chris thank you
for the time and good luck with the show
I really appreciate you asking those
amazing questions continue to believe
everyone and we'll see you soon sorry
bro